[Music]
hey Peter
dude did you play more octopus traveler
this weekend yeah it felt like I played
a lot longer than I actually did mm-hmm
I'm finding the game I like it yeah but
it's taken me a while to really get into
it that's how I felt I think I'm about
35 hours in but as far as what we are
allowed to talk about for the preview
Martin whatever I I've got all the
characters the main characters out of
the 8 obviously Beth but you and I were
talking about we both like it but it's
there are a lot of flaws with it at
least so far and it's kind of hard to
say why we like it until you really
think about it yeah I mean thinking
about it I can certainly nail very
specific aspects but the main thing I
keep coming back to that I keep
struggling with is the fact that I have
not yet hit a story or a plot that
really ties all these characters
together and justifies why we're going
on these adventures in the bigger
picture yeah I know that I can play as a
huntress who's you know looking for her
lost master and and stuff like that that
makes sense for each individual
character but the rest of it I'm kind of
just like going along waiting for
something to happen yeah it's cool how
its structured as far as you can get
them in any order you want but the world
itself is a ring right for the most part
so then you can get like I started with
the Huntress and then I went down to get
theory and the thief and then elf in the
apothecary but the problem I have with
the writing as much as I like the
structure is that even when you already
have three characters or four characters
when you go and recruit the next one and
you do not just their origin story which
they all do but by themselves but the
actual beginning of their quest as a
group they don't acknowledge that they
have seven companions no and then they
get together on the thinnest pretenses
it's basically like you join the mid
conversation after a fade to black
you're supposed to just assume the
conversation began between your two
parties and then you just say yeah I'll
help you out and that's about it so many
games that this is meant to you know
evoke the spirit of right like say Final
Fantasy 6 obviously Seiken Densetsu is
you know the sequel to Secret of Mana is
a big one but some of those games you
meet characters organically through you
know going through a bigger plot so the
fact that this is such a mechanical
rigid way of building your party and
getting the story started that's got me
feeling a little skeptical yeah but that
aside I'm really loving the combat first
of yeah that's definitely the combat I
was trying to describe it
there's a leat like a designer and a
producer from the bravely default
bravely second that series they are
working on here so you can kind of if
you play those games you can imagine how
you can save up battle points boost
essentially like unleash these all-out
attack so you can save up five but you
can only use four at a time I believe
and then you can just unload a lot of
damage on people if you've been patient
for a previous term yeah it's different
from the bravely games because you're
not sacrificing a turn to then have
vegetable moves in the future turn it's
like literally as long as you don't
spend battle points you'll earn another
one for the next round yeah and you know
the critical mechanic that all this
plays into is breaking your enemy
essentially disrupting their their place
in the the order of who goes next the
vulnerabilities are a big deal the game
makes it very clear like what can damage
an enemy but you have to figure that out
but once you know then it's all about
okay when is their turn next what
options do I have in my party to disable
them before their turn comes that can be
easier said than done bosses at this
point are starting to ramp up and have
like a shield of seven points which
means I need to hit them with seven of
something they're vulnerable way to be
able to even break them in the first
place that's where the boosting gets
interesting because you can save up the
boost for when they are stun and they're
going to take more damage it'll
sometimes you want to spend all of it
though just to get your game yeah
especially when you fight bosses where
it's like ten shields and they're
vulnerable and we'll settle lerczak
they're vulnerable to bow and arrows and
Spears right one character's bow and
arrow you hit them with all for all of
your boots so that'll bring the shields
out of five and stun them and then you
have like my scholar Syrus he is pretty
much my damage dealing character in
general with elemental attacks so then
I'll just like unleash firestorm on them
once they're stun but I like the dynamic
between that I think like if people who
played persona 5 might be sort of
familiar with once you stun everybody in
on the enemy team you could do an
all-out attack that's not the case here
but each individual character can
essentially do an all-out attack right I
mean once an enemy is broken every hit
is essentially a critical hit I am
finding the I'm not sure that I like the
fact that magic when you boost it isn't
increasing the number of magic hits it's
just sort of increasing the strength of
the magic
yeah and like weapons some characters
our enemies are vulnerable to different
types of magic so you really have to
pick and choose like how you're piling
on the attacks it gives you a lot to
think about yeah because yeah like to
mention Syrus he gets attacks that are
like you can deal lightening fire or ice
damage to everybody twice that's the
most I've seen that you can do with
magic yeah outside of like you said
boosting doesn't increase the number of
times you hit right but it does kind of
I sort of like it cuz it makes me think
about magic differently but you already
do anyway though I guess I would like it
if it actually was a quantity of hits
and then yeah like I like how all the
different classes complement each other
I thought the merchants might be boring
and I thought the apothecary might be
boring but I think elfin the apothecary
is my favorite character in combat
outside of the Huntress who I picked his
concoctions you can essentially cure any
status ailments and then when you unlock
more jobs he's kind of a light medic but
he's more like a triage first-aid kind
of get rid of poison right wake someone
up without using an item he's also a bit
of a tank because one of his support
skills that you unlock semi early on is
a huge boost to his HP yeah so like the
classes and the characters feel very
distinct from one another yeah certainly
so while I'm not necessarily in love
with them outside of combat everyone
really has their own value even though
if like at first I'm like I don't know
if I'm gonna like this character this
archetype they have some skill that
makes them really valuable yeah and like
over time obviously like I'm really
really I'd mentioned it earlier but
despite the fact that I have a lot of
problems with writing itself in the
dialogue and the how most of the
characters are presented I really really
like how the world is structured as far
as your recruiting the eight characters
it's it's just a ring a little sort of
so again you can go counterclockwise and
go clockwise and gameplay-wise it
accounts for that again like the story
might not as well but after that you
start branching outward is like a second
level of the spiral to do their second
the second phase of all the requests and
like you said there's no problem I have
is there's no unifying story they just
like you know supposedly you're opposed
to assume these seven people are helping
Hani to find her master and so when you
go do that that's the only story you're
focusing on or these seven people are
helping elfin travel the world to help
people in medical need but so far
there's no sort of discussion among them
yeah themselves right
the
inner party interactions you get our
moment when they join forces and it's
the most thin agreement of cooperation
yeah and supposedly there is like
contextual dialogue later while you're
traveling yeah I haven't encountered
that yet but I don't even think that
would account for the fact that like
when you I don't know if I'm pronouncing
oberek or oberek the warrior when you go
to fight the people with him everybody
like you're gonna go do this by yourself
but then in my head I'm like no I have
six other people recruited what are they
talking about it doesn't account for
that and I kind of wish more time had
gone into making everything feel
contextual do like some of the
characters a lot I like elephants he's
endearing and then you know like later
on his story develops in a different way
but I it's also because there's eight
different stories it feels so up and
down like I love hunting for combat but
the writing in suare key I'm not sure if
I'm pronouncing that right but her
hometown is just so high fantasy like
using this right go into the forest yeah
one on you I don't see you look you're
young data can you see
she no not have a car
kind of it's a bit of a chore to read
and get through all of that and that's
kind of what I feel like as I'm doing is
I'm completing chores by collecting
these characters you know a full party
in combat is for yeah and I almost once
I hit my fourth character I almost
thought like do I just sort of push the
boundaries and continue on to chapter
two for the characters I have already
recruited and not even bother with the
ones that I haven't met I'm curious if
that's possible with this scheme I'm
gonna recruit them all because I gotta
see what they're all like I'd say if you
grind enough it would be possible but I
do think the game does a good job of
giving you enemies in certain areas that
certain characters are way better
against like say yeah if you don't have
fairy and the thief or Cyrus then
enemies with only a fire weakness are
gonna be tougher because you don't have
fire attacks so a but if you have the
awesome hunter she can get enemies if
you can capture enemies to have a fire
element
yeah she's got like a Pokemon light
aspect to her kind of gonna get a
limited time use with her essentially a
blue mage and final fantasy okay speak
as a game that's clearly like playing on
the Stahl job I mean there's more to it
than that obviously from what we've said
but visually in terms of its structure
as you know like an old-school JRPG it's
clearly playing on like riffing on those
old tropes do you think it's to its
detriment so far do you think it's a
really good omage with its own little
twist on the formula I mean I think it's
a good Oh Molly I am again I am missing
the broader epic story so I'm hoping
that comes you know if you really just
want to talk about the presentation of
the game it really nails the the
PlayStation era mix of pixelated 2d
textures and simple 3d models it's the
sort of thing that reminds me of
Xenogears or Breath of Fire 3 or 4 I'm
finding myself marveling at the sort of
visual effects that go into making this
pixel art so attractive and it's it's
it's a dreamy game you know it's very
soft there's a lot of things that are
out of focus to create depth of field
there's almost always a vignette around
the edge of the screen yeah that's sort
of that's what I was looking for and
that that is what is what they're going
for and you know sometimes with the
somewhat dull writing and that I find
myself getting a little sleepy playing
this like yeah if it's not a really
exciting moment but I like the fact that
they've experimented in this way I do
find myself thinking that the character
sprites are a little bit too small and
yeah enemies in particularly the bosses
have this wonderful level of detail and
sort of like grim little twists they may
look like at one point you fight like a
deranged rat looking thing which in the
overworld just looks kind of innocuous
but in the game it's this it's got this
very sort of like fiendish pose and it's
drooling from the mouth and you can
really tell it's eyes are crazy and that
goes back to like how they did Kefka and
yes that seems sort of just exaggerated
like grandiose representation which
looks great like I really like that a
lot yeah despite like the numerous flaws
I'm seeing with it it's reminding me of
the bravely games in the sense that I'm
still having a ton of fun with it but
the game doesn't comes out in about a
week week and a half ish time seems
fairly long from this far as I've gotten
we can't talk too much more past that
point but right I'm excited about it so
far
decide to see how other people think
yeah I really hope that if I put a
little bit more time into this that I'll
find a story that that matches all the
excellent stuff around it cuz so far
this game shows a lot of promise just
might take a while to really get there
and show it off yeah
well get back to work you have to review
it I don't